alors l'insécurité et particulièrement
dans les transports c'était aussi le
thème de ce nouveau déplacement de
jacques chirac à mantes-la-jolie dans
les yvelines
à certains proches du chef de l'état le
juger trop sur la réserve dans cette
campagne
cette visite devait donc marquer un
durcissement de ton jacques chirac a
effectivement dénoncer je cite une
culture de la permissivité mais sans
jamais citer le gouvernement reportage
véronique saint-aulaye finition il
fallait sécuriser des tours où la police
ne pénètrent plus à quartier tristement
célèbre pour son insécurité
après un court trajet dans le bus mis à
sa disposition jacques chirac a plongé
au coeur d'une foule au sentiment mitigé
d'un coin qui est bien chaud ici et puis
la silla de la force de venir jusqu'à là
bas un pékin
quand je pense à fernande sa place à
l'ept la santé la bousculade est
indescriptible les policiers en civil ne
maîtrise plus rien le candidat jacques
chirac investi le terrain à sa façon et
renvoie ainsi l'accusation de campagne
molle à la gare de mantes la jolie le
poste de police est complètement blindés
on explique les interventions dans les
trains et les bus la présence dissuasive
des accompagnateurs et des contrôleurs
jacques chirac est venu pour ça décliné
le thème de la sécurité dans les
transports
face à lionel jospin qui réserve ses
propositions pour fin mars jacques
chirac dénonce tout de suite la
permissivité et le laxisme qui serait
socialiste pour quoi que on ne change
pas la justice en france pourquoi qu'on
ne change pas cette politique actuelle
il ya une impunité la règle générale
c'est l'impunité tout acte délictueux
non seulement dans les transports en
commun meilleur doit faire l'objet d'une
réponse judiciaire rapide à la sortie
jacques chirac ne sourit pas longtemps
les crachats soudain pleuvent des
enfants d'une douzaine d'années urnes en
le traitant de voleur
il construit les temps l'autorité à ce
cp le candidat jacques chirac a du pain
sur la planche
bon ben ouais